so continuing our discussion on Secret
Wars the events in this story provide us
with some insight into what happened to
the various characters who were
transported across battle world by
Doctor Strange prior to his death at the
hands of doom but also brings the
rumblings of revolution into full swing
before we get into this though something
I want to touch on here are the
territories of bar-sinister
and Ferno and Age of Apocalypse due to
the fact that the armies of these three
territories will be a major part of the
revolution in this story bar-sinister is
pretty straightforward and that is run
by mr. sinister presumably the version
from the main Marvel Universe and
occupied entirely of clones of himself
Inferno is a territory based on the 1988
story of the same name where it was
revealed that a woman named Madeline
prior was a clone of Jean Grey created
by mr. sinister and introduced after
Jean Grey died in an effort to procreate
with Scott Summers and produce a child
with incredible power who would actually
go on to become cable during the
infernal event
Madeline Pryor had lost her mind after
learning that she was a clone and in
turn I lied herself with demons from the
dimension of limbo attended an invasion
and takeover of earth but ultimately
failed however in terms of the battle
world territory and the character that
we'll see in this story this version of
Madeline hails from a universe where she
was successful in taking over the world
finally Age of Apocalypse is another
straightforward story which focus on a
universe where apocalypse was never
destroyed by Magneto during the Age of
Apocalypse event and instead continued
to rule the world now in terms of Secret
Wars when we covered issues 4 & 5 I left
out a couple of segments since I didn't
play a major role at the time but
because of the events taking place in
part 7 we need to jump back and cover a
couple of these things an issue number
four when Doctor Strange had stood
against doom over the fact that he had
create a battle world as a testing
ground rather than a utopia
during the conflict strange a teleported
the survivors of the ultimate universe
and the main Marvel Universe to
different locations across battle world
where issues 5 & 6 largely focus on both
versions of Reed Richards from the
Ultimate Universe and may marvel
universe respectively as well as Peter
Parker and Miles Morales and their
efforts to locate the source of dooms
power and eliminate it the story also
explained what happened to Jane Foster
Thor Carol Danvers Black Panther and
name of the Submariner while it's only
given over a single page Jane Foster had
been transported a doomguard the
location with the Thor Corps resides as
a police force about a world under doom
Panther and then when the Submariner had
been transported to Egyptian a section a
battle war from a universe where Moses
never led an exodus from Egypt and Carol
Danvers had been sent to bar-sinister in
addition to this with our last video we
a touched on the idea of an enigmatic
being named the Prophet leading a
revolution and battleworld taking a sort
of Game of Thrones attitude to the story
take - Tobler said on its face the
bearers of battleworld
under doom were all loyal without
question but in truth were completely
split down the middle now something I
want to do here real quick is talk about
maestro with a future and perfect story
so I'm stuck in his own head and
destined to spend the rest of his life
believing that he had defeated doom in
the main secret war story he's in his
normal form and perfectly aware of
everything that's going on while Hickman
may or may not explain how this happened
this particular issue is one of the
reasons why tie-ins can be a problem for
major stories there's no real unifying
element except for the story itself and
so we don't really have a choice here
but to assume that either the tie-in
didn't happen or something took place to
rouse the maestro out of his illusion
but regardless in terms of the story
what Hickman does here is play on the
arrogance of doom and that he assumes
that his barons are loyal to a fault
while some like apocalypse follow doom
due to his belief of survival of the
fittest and only the strongest should
rule others like sinister have more
ambiguous motives and so all of this
comes to a head in issue number seven
when we pick up with a fallout of the
prophets revolt growing beyond control
amassing an army huge in size and
composed of various characters from
throughout battle world some of whom
have powers of some of whom don't the
revolution comes knocking on the door of
doom stat where it's revealed that the
Prophet is none other than Maximus the
mad now for those who are unaware
Maximus is the inhuman brother of Black
Bolt king of the Inhumans but also
possesses a genius-level intellect as a
result of his exposure to the Terrigen
mists like the other survivors of the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
Universe Maximus seems to be leading
this revolution for the purpose of
toppling doom whether this is due to
altruism and that he's trying to do the
right thing or because he has his own
motives is unknown
since Maximus himself is ambiguous when
it comes to his motives for any
particular situation however the schemes
of Maximus are short-lived in the face
of the combined efforts of bar-sinister
Madeline Pryor and her goblins and
apocalypses forces seeing this as an
opportunity to turn against Duman in his
rule send us return codes and along with
Carole Dan
their forces attack Madeline Pryor and
her army of goblins however in the mists
of their attack on Madeline enter
goblins sinister is caught unawares by
an explosion from behind resulting in
his head being severed from his neck and
when the smoke clears he's greeted by
the arrival of Holocaust decide track
for a second Holocaust was it being
originating from the age of hawk ellipse
story with unknown origins while it was
claimed that he was the son of
apocalypse this is largely left
ambiguous and instead he simply served
as one of apocalypses four horsemen
furthermore with apocalypse arriving on
the battlefield the indication from
Hickman seems to be that because
apocalypse was serving as a baron of the
Age of Apocalypse territory but was
unable to move outside of his own
boundaries he quite literally grew bored
of stagnation as a result he delights in
the idea of being on a battlefield and
testing the weak so that they can prove
themselves strong or be destroyed and so
after a bit of banter between apocalypse
and sinister himself the battlefield is
met with the arrival of the Thor Corps
however rather than being there for the
purpose of quilling the conflict it's
revealed that Jane Foster has incited
revolution within the range of the Thor
Corps after revealing the truth of
battle world and that doom is not a god
but an all-powerful being who pulled
realities together after the collapse of
the multiverse as a result the Thor
Corps is in complete and total disarray
with civil war breaking out between
those who believe Jane Foster and those
who don't
where the battle is short-lived with
Jane Foster ultimate Thor and others
coming out on top the group takes their
leave from doom guard at which point the
entire battlefield descends into
complete and total chaos with the
remnants of the Thor Corps fighting
against the forces of apocalypse and
Madeline prior by allying themselves
against doom with sinister and Carol
Danvers Susan storm flurry Richards and
Black Swan watch alongside doom as a
situation unfolds now what hitman does
here is used a situation to provide
dissent among the ranks of Doom zone
house and that to Susan storm the Thor
course war absolute allegiance to doom
and has obeyed every order without
question however suddenly the Thor Corps
has turned against doom indicating that
they know something that Susan doesn't
which is caused in the turn against doom
and join the revolution now back on the
battlefield
what Hickman does is provide those of us
who are apocalypse fans with a true
depiction of his power and that he
single-handedly is able to take on a
full contingent of the Thor Corps if I
can be a little bold here this is
particularly awesome to me because I've
been an epochal
fan for years and I felt like this
display was a reflection of just how
powerful of pocalypse
is end up between a shape-shifting
control of his atomic structure and so
on he's someone that could easily stand
against some of the strongest foes
however in the midst of the fight the
battlefield is met with the arrival of
maestro and his army of hulks referred
to as the world breakers all of whom
possess the same level of strength as
world breaker Hulk from the world war
hulk storyline at this point we
transition to project 42 with the
ultimate and main Marvel versions of
Reed Richards what we learn is that this
entire revolution as it's being led by
Maximus including Sinister's betrayal
and the arrival of the folks has all
been orchestrated by ultimate read as a
distraction that will allow himself the
main Marvel read and star-lord to enter
the castle of doom alongside black
panther with the Infinity Gauntlet and
in his rule now the conversation between
Reed Richards and Black Panther is of
stupendous importance here and that the
two are extremely close friends by way
of their intelligence as well as the
experiences that they've shared as part
of the Illuminati and so the two
recognized that their mission is quite
literally a last-ditch effort scenario
and that if they fail they will likely
die and battleworld will continue under
the rule of doom was also funny here is
the banter between Black Panther and
named warg as sworn enemies who both
annihilated the others Empire during
time runs out leading up to secret Wars
the conversation between the two is
filled with chives as much as it is
animosity and so I think a legitimate
argument can be made here that even if
the two aren't the best of friends at
the very least they share a common
respect for one another and so with the
two standing before the wall separating
battle world from the dead and Ultron
robots Black Panther destroys the wall
and enters using the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet my Panther is able to
curb the zombies desire for flesh and in
the process offer them a chance to use
the siege courageous to eliminate the
zombie plague from their bodies and
start their lives anew while some stand
against the idea and that they view
their lives as simple due to the fact
that they simply exist to eat flesh and
can't truly die because all of them were
heroes or super-powered beings in some
form or fashion prior to contracted a
zombie plague black panther appeals to
this aspect of the personalities by
telling them that should they choose to
use a siege courageous to start over
they can fight alongside black panther
for glory and honor
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you guys later peace